maintenant je vous fait envie pour vous
une interview nul en ébauche par le
single
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai peur comme celui baptiste vaut
absolument une baffe y est convaincu
convaincu jean baptiste aussi cette
famille de mon mari bat marié ah oui
c'est une tradition familiale d'alison
chez vos convictions
d'accord je respecte toutes les
convictions tout celle là surtout celle
là oui alors interview nuls dont j'ai
les questions très très con je pourrais
prendre qu'à nous bah y'a pas toi et moi
je sais bien les poser je pensais alors
est ce que vous préférez pierre ou
ginette j'avais dit que c'était qu'on
s'est on parle des mêmes ouais parce
qu'il va beaucoup de meilleure énergie
c'est votre pierre pote papa pierre et
votre maman ginette non pas faire un
choix entre ses paras s'il faut avant
tout les deux c'est un formidable et 2
donc on va pas choisir sincèrement vous
arrivez pas là non
entre hitler et staline vous préférez
acquis
à vous en foutez c'est pas vos parents
là tous les deux non il n'y a pas de
troisième a choisi j'avais ma route
c'est tout mais c'est le pire bien alors
vous partez dans un vaisseau spatial
pendant trois ans je crains le pire
alors sur une île déserte avec qui
danser le vaisseau spatial qui vous
préféré partir
cantona tapis ou locaux un récent
problème comment je vais apprendre des
choses
ah oui ça c'est sûr c'est d'apprendre
des trucs elle n'avait pas négativement
on aime on n'aime pas oui mais il laisse
pas indifférent c'est moi j'ai beaucoup
appris il m'a dit beaucoup de vérité
est-ce que vous préféreriez mourir tout
de suite là maintenant pas vraiment et
aller au paradis ou vivre trente ans de
plus et aller en enfer
je prends les trente ans ouais pas grave
après on est sûr de rien après ça on est
pas d'accord car j'avais des heures car
il est là bien c'est idéal et de désir
de vous préféré partir avec une fille
très moche c'est un mec très beau
pour aller à la pêche ouais alors à
pêche au thon alors autant
alors oui c'est dur que ces questions
congrès c'est vraiment con j'ai répondu
comme maintenant je sais pas bon avec la
fiq un fil très moche ouais de taper des
du tout
non vraiment pas non j'ai vraiment sûre
si le désert partir lyonnais qu'on en
parle à chaque fois si vous partez sur
une île déserte doit être la même à mon
avis parce qu'alors les chanter là il y
avait des choses parce qu'alain sa vie
la langue et des roseaux là j'y vais pas
merci les filles qui envoient des emails
deux ans moi si samuel le bihan vu une
fille moche c'est si guillaume canet
avait une fille moche je suis d'accord
vous feriez quoi ou parier si moche ou m
non mais vous savez moi je m'excuse mais
très beau système
ces mecs
je me laissais inverse j'ai pas je vais
pas inversée dès lors qu'elle est moche
très moche très moche que la file très
bon oeil un mec très moche ce trouble
est très intelligent bon voilà fait très
belle est forcément très qu'on souhaite
ça m'arrange
bien celle-là et terry vous préféreriez
adopter des jumeaux cleptomane ou des
jumelles pyromanes j'avais averti
cleptomane alors des jumeaux club thomas
oui parce que des jumelles si romain
dans la région vous vivez en plus c'est
mieux que les poteaux moi ça ramène des
trucs à la maison je pouvais être
regardé en slip de sega en slip de
tibéri ou en slip de delanoë en fait pas
considéré comme vous je crois que si
vite
donc maintenant on va vous faire c'est
terrible c'est ici je suis vraiment
embêté que ça tombe sur vous mais bon en
même temps c'est l'interview nul en les
bouches pendant les tigres
[Applaudissements]
moi
bien vous préférez hitler ou staline ni
l'un ni l'autre à faut choisir camarades
et riche ouais bien emmerdés c'est
impossible de répondre à une question il
ya quelques années un communiste a
répondu c'est à dire oui les temps
changent quand même de times they are
a-changin' comme disait bob dylan ouest
à l'erp
ouais alors vous devez partir de 3 ans
dans un vaisseau spatial fameux vaisseau
spatial peut-être très abîmée depuis le
temps vous préféré partir avec alain
duhamel
arlette chabot et je sais où jean pierre
elkabbach
ah oui ça je sais c'est terrible
choisissez le moins pire
ouais je prends de la faim d'arlette
chabot arlette chabot à vous faire vous
préférez un président la république
d'extrême droite élu au suffrage
universel ou annuler le processus
démocratique annulé processus
démocratique s'est passé en algérie
vous préférez annuler le processus d je
préfère annuler procède à un moment
aussi à présent un public extrêmement
attachant atomique
donc vous n'êtes pas démocrate pas
démocratique on né peut pas démocrate
jusqu'au bout avait d'accord pas de
liberté pour les ennemis de la liberté
quoi un peu oui
vous n'êtes pas complètement changé
encore non mais ça viendra peut-être
mais sur cette question là j'aimerais
pas changé oui vous aimeriez avoir un
nez supplémentaires un doigt
supplémentaire ou un sexe
supplémentaires années supplémentaires
ça me servira à rien un sac
supplémentaire qu'on peut compliquer un
doigt supplémenté un doigt oui
exactement
avec ce défi en plus au sexe vous
pourriez avoir un sexe deux filles
ouais non je le dois sexe de fil souple
et non non non non produits c'est dur à
gérer
oui c'est dur à gérer vous savez ça
c'est nickel mais vous n'aurez plus
besoin de l'alsacien ce moment là ces
histoires d'alsaciens savez si on à 2,5
pour mieux voir es tu vois je suis plus
proche lambie blessures laurent baffie
le patron de marianne
à votre avis quel est le sport le plus
con j'ai pas il ya un sport que j'aime
pas sur le coup le curling
j'allais le dire bravo ça c'est dans
l'est c'est ça oui c'est ce que je vais
vous citer way le curling c'est qu'on le
curling
il ya un mec qui balaie tu verrais il ya
un mec qui balaient devant un truc là on
pouvait c'est quoi le sport le plus con
pour vous le cricket parce qu'il est
compliqué ouais on voi le mec qui se
fait ici à chelsea
[Rires]
si vous étiez en vente dans un sex shop
vous seriez quoi si j'étais en vendant
un sex-shop je serai quoi nous faudra
latex non non pour une cassette vidéo
ouais ouais c'est bien il faut dans le
texte pourquoi wild rose vous vous laver
les cheveux tous les combien tous les
jours tous les jours alors imaginez vous
deviez partir sur une île déserte
oui sans jeu l'esprit bien sûr vous
partiriez avec une frite d'esprit vous
partiriez avec une fille très moche ou
un mec très beau
non vous décevoir non avec un autre beau
donc vous êtes un peu non mais je
préfère le mot
ah ouais mais qu'est ce que vous feriez
sur cette île je voulais de cette
manière il ne sera pas d'israël n'est
pas complètement fermée au truc quand
même mois aux actes pour partir avec
quoi ça deviendrait moins en moins moi
je suis en tout cas tout le moins en
moins moi je vous dis une semaine à qui
attribuez vous le plus de circonstances
atténuantes
un vieux qui se tape des petites ou un
jeune qui tape sur les vieilles jeunes
qui tapent sur des vieilles ouais bon il
ya au moins de quelques quelques raisons
de le faire
à saint denis en même temps c'est
courant mais moi ça me pour puce quad en
huitièmes dagger dans le 8ème c'est
plutôt les vieux qui se tape des petites
comme je suis sidéré par cette réponse
oui bah moi aussi oui c'est comme le
fait qu'ils partent avec un léger déclin
naturel si j'ose dire c'est peut-être
critiquable mais ces six jours
discipline est dure à elle que quand on
est un jeune de t'appeler sur les
vieilles en moi je vous prends ça plus
naturel imaginez que vous vous
réincarner en slip
vous préféreriez être le slip de
françois hollande
j'essaie c'est dur de laurent fabius et
en dehors du parti socialiste vous
n'avez pas d'autres tout le nord est et
de qui patrick je vais essayer de faire
en sorte de passer au slip et puis je
dirais henri emmanuelli mais c'est
normal c'est celui qui est le plus
proche de vos idées mais c'est peut-être
pas exhaustive il vaut mieux aussi
l'interview nul il vaut mieux être riche
et qu'on use intelligent et pauvres
pour intelligent et pauvres intelligent
et pauvres ouais d'accord avec ça on est
intelligent et riche et pas mal non plus
et mieux
c'est une question qui est arrivée par
e-mail de jean-philippe de liège encore
un belge
ouais et vous préfériez quoi alors être
riche et quant aux intelligents et
pauvres ce qu'on va faire maintenant
une interview qui s'appelle l'interview
nulle part alors première question est
ce que vous préfériez votre père ou
votre mère ça dépend des moments de ma
vie
ouais est ce que vous préférez hitler ou
staline
je n'aime ni l'un ni l'autre alors vous
devez partir de 3 ans dans un vaisseau
spatial vous préféré partir avec gérard
muller au moins leur parler serge
klarsfeld ou elie wiesel lui ammann ni
d'idées mais ce soir on ne peut discuter
pour combien de temps d'enlever trois
ans 3 ans et 3 ans et les deux autres
trois en fait les visuels ces temps-ci
là il est libre alors savez vous ce
qu'est devenu jean roucas
non est ce que vous préférez un
président d'extrême droite élu au
suffrage universel où on annule les
élections je préférais ont déjà nul
c'est quoi ça vous avez vu ce que ça a
donné en algérie quand on a dû les
élections parce qu'elle nous
déplaisaient pour moi je veux aussi à
des élections il ya des élections
gérard ben je me permets de rappel
février trek il sait aussi bien que
n'importe qui
hitler est venu au pouvoir par des
élections mussolini aussi par exemple
mais c'est bien pour cela le disais tout
à l'heure que les allemands et les nazis
c'était la même chose mais je les la
laonnoise légèrement mieux plus solides
comme hitler c'est vraiment les
élections oui le plus problème de la
démocratie c'est qu'elle est assez fait
pour laisser parfois venir à sa tête des
gens qui veulent la détruire oncle du
mot crossfit
je trouve simplement qu'il faut faire en
sorte que les ennemis de la démocratie
n'est pas la possibilité tout aussi
limitée voici ce à moi je suis brune
démocratie si vous pouviez avoir un truc
en plus vous choisiriez un nez et un
oeil ou un saint comme adamo 3 ça oui ah
bon tu as une chambre un accueil ou un
saint lô l'oeil derrière bridier vous
partez sur une île déserte pendant deux
ans cette fois vous préféré partir avec
un maître très beau ou une fille très
moche je suis très moche en deux ans
deux ans parce qu'il est déjà parti avec
jarre milliards dans l'espace
je ne demande pas pardon
c'est
et oui ça vous arrive on va faire
l'interview nul on ne bouge pas pendant
le jingle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous préférez hitler ou
staline c'est trop difficile hitler
certainement pas non plus mais enfin de
deux mois je choisirais plutôt maline
d'accord parce qu'il a tué plus de gens
pas finance pas pour ça mais parce que
je crois qu'il peut être une certaine
époque que certaines choses
l'idée reçue par et un départ même si
j'étais totalement dénaturé alors vous
devez partir trois ans dans un vaisseau
spatial
vous avez le choix entre jean pierre
chevènement quelle horreur jean louis
debré à jean marie le pen
c'est abominable ouais je crois que je
pars avec jean pierre chevènement mais
avant de partir je me débrouille pour
que se crée dans le territoire de
belfort à un mouvement indépendantiste
très virulente pour qu'il attendrait son
retour quelqu un qui vous accorder de
plus de circonstances atténuantes
un vieux qui se tape des petites ou un
jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles non il
ya aucune circonstance atténuante c'est
pas possible souvent qu'à leur père ne
savait pas eu lieu en corse la vague
anti voile chez elle vous touchez à des
choses qui sont sacrées chez nous les
enfants et les vieillards
chez nous aussi sacré vous inquiétez pas
ce qui vous j'aimerais le plus ça serait
d'être surpris un jeu de l'esprit palam
d'être surpris au lit avec un make way
deux filles avec un mec ça ne me paraît
difficile pour le moment ça peut changer
mon fin pour le moment il y ce qui me
gênerait le plus fou c'est d'être
surpris au lit avec un mec avec deux
filles avec un mac et vous aussi compte
tenu de ce que vous évitiez là ça serait
ça me gênerait d'être surprise au lit
avec un mec vous aimeriez avoir années
supplémentaires un acte supplémentaire
un doigt supplémentaire ou un sexe
supplémentaires un oeil derrière
derrière c'est normal c'est la corse
on est bloqué tous les deux dans une
bergerie dans la montagne vous et moi il
ya la police française tout autour qui
nous assiège je leur donne raison
bah parce que je sais pas parce qu'on
est des cons a pris le maquis en et des
raies c'est un jeu de l'esprit un jeu
meurent de froid ce qu'il fait froid là
où je meurs de froid une bergerie de
haute montagne
oui je meurs de froid vous êtes obligé
de me manger vous commencez par quoi non
ce ne peut pas arriver ça super est
bloqué dans une bergerie avec moi et
qu'on est susceptible d'être encerclés
par la police sur un tunnel
actionnaires
puis comme votre groupe sap et les
stouts ecclestone se veut dire les nuls
je vous faire l'interview nul en à
gauche pendant le signal on ne bouge pas
pendant
ne bouge pas pendant le génial yoo move
de jogging de musique non vous avez
bougé par la musique non les caf au
légué est ce que vous préférez votre
père votre mère phare de ce droit le
père est vivant et vivant est ce que
vous préférez staline ou hitler
heatley mais honnêtement le provocateur
que si vous partez trois ans dans un
vaisseau spatial est ce que vous
préférez partir soit une spaceship
est-ce que vous préféré partir avec
madonna mariah carey jennifer lopez
britney spears ou janet jackson jennifer
lopez les pieds sur terre d'accueil
alors vous devez partir sur une île
déserte
est-ce que vous préféré partir avec un
mec très beau ou avec une fille très
laide
d'accord j'ai qu'il fit très laide
oui les mecs très beau c'est vraiment
des casses pieds et vos questions ont
peu varié partir les km très beau une
fille très laide bien ni dit le mot le
plus con en amour
est-ce que c'est merci encore
ou oui oui bon
votre émission préférée
est ce que c'est d'être peint ces mordus
ou piquer à il avait entendu vous le
saurez les filles si vous deviez rayer
une ville de la carte laquelle je
n'étais sans gêne sur abc hollywood
quel est l'animal qui embrasse le mieux
et pourra les ids norvège est ce que ça
voulait mourir comme otis redding dans
un crash d'avion comme john lennon
abattu à bout portant
comme john bonham le batteur de led
zeppelin qui est mort en s'étouffant
dans son vomi et oui je ne dis pas que
je sais c'est la vérité c'est l'histoire
du rock'n'roll j'aime bien c'est comme
ça et oui ou comme janis joplin d'une
overdose un accident d'avion comme otis
redding dans l'accident d'avion aucune
culpabilité pas d'erreur et guy si vous
étiez en vente dans un sex shop vous
voudriez être quoi à un soutien-gorge
loisirs rien de trop question si vous
étiez en vendant un sex-shop voudriez
être quoi une crème
c'est vivre dernière question le hip hop
une question stupide mais qui n'est pas
de moi celle là aimez-vous les chiens
oui oui encore comment il s'appelle
trombe à iggy pop qui dénote son nouveau
cd je vaux mieux elle est visible
la boucle est bon
je
saint-cloud fantômes et merci d'être
venu hip-hop et à bientôt et garder la
france perd
[Applaudissements]
non
du dieu on ne bouge pas pendant le team
en cours devant les fourneaux pour ne
bouge pas pendant le génial
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
thierry roland est ce que vous préférez
staline ou hitler vous dire ni l'autre
n'ont pas les gens qui dit jeu tallinn
est un peu mieux non non vous c'est
pareil wes kaka le mot le plus con en
amour c'est merci encore
ou oui oui oui oui c'est que le 28 voix
séparaient oui merci ses congés ainsi
cet exercice est vraiment né là merci
madame merci pour le petit cadeau non
c'est mieux les bouge encore encore
bravo ses coûts non je trouve ça très
bien mais c'est fatigant alors vous
partez trois ans un vaisseau spatial
vous avez le choix entre trois passagers
gérard holtz
ça commence bien
charles bietry y vas y est gérard muller
j'ai eu chaud que l'épaule enfin c'est
suffisamment pour savoir si les rôles
bien sûr je sais qu'il aime vivait à 3
minutes mais trois ans ouais bon cheval
isabelle alonso là bas je vais vous
surprendre
oui j'ai aussi reprend ouais je
prendrais gérard oury bah oui parce que
moi vous parlerez de sport et voit alors
que miller j'essaierai de le gérer de le
convaincre que je suis pas les normes
merde qui croient que je suis est
sexuellement ça vous dérange pas que pas
prendre alonso non bons acquis
accordez-vous le plus de circonstances
atténuantes
un vieux qui se tape des jeunes où un
jeune qui tapent sur des vieux qui se
tape des ingénieurs que je tape des
jeunes déjà lieu
du sexe opposé déjà accepté des mecs un
ami entre chez vous il avance chez vous
une voix dans votre chambre à
l'improviste ce qui vous gêne le plus
qu'ils trouvent sur la table de chevet
c'est mind chaos ou un godemiché mein
kampf avec moi bien alors vous préfériez
passé la nuit avec anne sinclair lors
sinclair ou bob sinclair lors sinclair
lors sinclair pas très gentil pour anne
sinclair quand même c'est pas grave donc
comme canal c'est les nuls
on va vous faire une interview nul en a
beaucoup
[Musique]
hu
et le graphisme ne passera pas non mais
la lie sa bulle là c'est pas mal et
c'est bien
car est ce que vous êtes prêts est ce
que vous préférez staline ou hitler
staline a dérivé il est devenu l'un des
pires tyrans et il a fait un mal
abominable et des millions de gens mais
au départ il s'agissait d'aider
l'ensemble de la population pauvre use
it passe en mémoire de votre père non
non non donc salines un peu mieux un peu
moins mal ouais parce qu'il a tué plus
de gens puissent était pas génocide
ouais il n'avait pas décréter que c'est
quand on envoie les gens en sibérie
enfin maintenant mais il n'avait pas
décréter qu'une race des sites et une
classe lui et pourquoi tu mets pas ma ou
danton quiz on pourrait le mettre
je le garde pour philippe sollers
d'accord vous partez trois ans dans un
vaisseau spatial
vous partez avec qui charles biétry
guillaume durand ou michel toulouse
j'en un mannequin ouais toulouse quand
même et l'originalité toulouse parce
qu'il a il a une imagination que quelque
chose a perverti sans doute dans son
application mais il continuait d'avoir
une imagination qui va être intéressante
et réjouissante dans ce voyage comme il
ya ce fameux voyage qui dure trois ans
quand même bien là si c'est pour écouter
les histoires de durant pendant pendant
trois révolutions qui comme tant de
billetterie pourra pas me commenter les
matchs en direct voilà d'accord est ce
que vous préférez faire l'amour avec une
fille très laide ou un mec très beau une
fille très laide ah ouais vous tapez des
détours
j'ai tellement de copains au mot que je
pense que si j'étais un soupçon d' homo
ça ce serait moi je le serai ouais mais
ça se sait
qui veut que vous préféreriez vous
réincarner en patrick le lay le patron
de tf1 marc tessier le patron de france
télévisions où nicolas de tavernost le
patron de m6 eh ben je vais vous dire un
truc là ouais
patrick le lay parce que ce qui m'est
pas défendable dans votre bouquin sur
lui là parce que c'est pas une vraie
détestation votre amour à ce qu'on
croyait il vous ils vous étonne quand
même il m'étonne pas ce qu'il fait des
trucs que je suis incapable de fait qui
merite deux claques et puis surtout un
type qui vers 40 ans alors qu'il a
construit des autoroutes les grands
bâtiments des plateformes de de pétrole
au large de l'océan
oui il lui dit francis lui dit patrick
up la télé ici mais après on peut
discuter plein de détails plein de
manière plate forme mais sur le fond
quel boulot magnifique
est ce que vous savez vous lécher la
langue ah non essayez là essaye de te
lécher la main dit impossible mais si tu
veux mon possible toutes les chaînes en
langue
il suffit de regarder les yeux
si vous aviez un perroquet oui est ce
que vous le prendriez comme phrase qui
devrait répéter comme ça toute la
journée
moi de charles est qu'à fermer le gaz tu
as pensé à la capote ou coco arrête là
coco tu à fermer le gaz 1 parce que j'ai
une famille maintenant faut que je pense
à tout le monde d'accord est-ce que vous
accepteriez de mourir comme ça là
maintenant si ça veut déjà il ya peu de
chances à priori 6 sv éradiquer pour
toujours la pauvreté sur la terre non
non parce que c'est une question vous
êtes jésus-christ un nom alors je perds
mais ça vous le saviez c'était dans tes
fiches au départ c'est trop facile de
lire 1 ben oui je suis prêt à mourir
tout de suite vous savez bien que je le
ferai quand celle ci s'était pas si tu
le feras si c'était possible je le fais
quand même dit oui on le faire est-ce
que vous préféreriez mourir alors
attention c'est très grave ça comme otis
redding dans un crash d'avion comme john
lennon abattu comme janis joplin dans
une overdose ou comme le mec des 6-10 y
est étouffé par son vomi évidemment atys
reding ouais marquer en ce moment c'est
peut-être bien parti mais qui me sert
los angeles je continue à le guen
beaucoup d'avions jusqu'à paris
voilà est-ce que vous aimeriez avoir un
nez supplémentaires sur dur c'est un peu
court et la terre un oeil
supplémentaires attention un doigt
supplémentaire ou un sexe
supplémentaires
un doigt un doigt toi tu prends la porte
envers les deux en même temps là
ils parlent plus qu'avec gilts à st il
met pas la main sur la cuisse a joué
aussi
gildas site mettait la main sur la
cuisse oui pour pas que tu parles
j'ai parfois souvent je pense qu'il dit
vrai pourquoi il fêté la main sur là
parce que c'était pas le moment parce
qu'il s'était pas maintenant qu'il avait
envie que je parle parce qu'il avait son
truc je voulais pas perdre le fil et
puis et puis la connerie c'est bien beau
mais lui voulait il voulait déroulée
sans câble et voilà quoi ces gentilles
qui dit lescure sur toi dans son bouquin
oui c'est une phrase en même temps bah
oui mais bon ya malheureusement beaucoup
de phrases qui sont pas gentils mais
choqué à l'époque de l'acharnement des
guignols à mon endroit il m'avait fait
passer des petits messages pour me dire
me faire dire qu'il n'était pas d'accord
et j'avais trouvé ça très gentil de la
part de pierre parce qu'ils n'étaient
pas obligés de vrais de faire ça quoi
pierre quel est à votre avis le sport le
plus con le fist fucking basij étoiles
le curling
oh oui c'est bien le me sens bien
rania histoire de béziers
en gérant vous ne serais pas étonné que
je vous fasse une interview nul n'en
tirait en embauchera pendant le tibia
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous préférez hitler staline
ben laden ou mao ont des causes que vous
demandez aucun des quatre bas il ya des
gens qui disent tallinn par exemple ob
rue ouais voilà le robert hue a été
relaxé non non non non aucun des quatre
noms parce qu'en plus j'ai vu j'ai vu là
la lada tchad staline à sotchi
ouais il y avait la guide était vraiment
terrorisé quand elle a eu les espèces de
statues de staline falloir à la
reproduction de quoi ces diktats on peut
pas aimer les dictateurs un peu sophie
marceau dire ça c'est des dictateurs on
peut pas attention ce soit phil marso
qui est une grande actrice comme dit
mathilde seigner ou bien vous devez
partir trois heures dans un vaisseau
spatial
oui trois ans dans un vaisseau spatial
préféré partir avec laure sinclair qui
va nous rejoindre tout à l'air d'aller à
à mme sinclair ou bob sinclair lors
sinclair alors s'incline par l arrêté le
porno en même temps je vous le dis
bonjour au scrabble
ouais
à qui accorder vous le plus de
circonstance et c'est pas tomber sur
vous avez du pot 1 qui accordez-vous le
plus de circonstances atténuantes
un vieux qui se tape des petites ou un
jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles un
jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles jeu
pas moins
ouais bah dit lundi l'autre mais bon si
j'allais mais qu'au-delà de 50 ans ils
disent aux vieux qui se tape des petites
crâne n'est pas encore dans celle ça
dépend ce que ce qui est petit des
problèmes majeurs ou pas avec ce sont
maintenant ça peut être que des majeures
avec la loi qui est passée sans heurts
majeurs oui oui praia pas les majeures
de 15 ans mais sur excitante aussi le
mot le plus con l'amour et vous vous y
connaissez
est-ce que c'est merci encore où
oui oui oui oui parce que ça rappelle
l'enfance ase appelle les looks à la
grace est cotée en bourse
je pose pas la question son aide non non
non cette question est encore plus du
tout
accepteriez-vous d'échanger une
paralysie générale contre la faim de la
famine dans l'afrique subsaharienne est
la vache à lait c'est vrai je peux pas
répondre là que vous n'êtes pas gentil
finalement moi mais je suis méchant
demandé à mathilde seigner
question alors à qui empruntent auriez
vous le plus volontiers son cerveau pour
une greffe me dit pologne non non jerry
cerveau je n'en veux pas j'aime beaucoup
de la dame alors à qui empruntent
feriez-vous et son cerveau pour une
greffe à valéry giscard d'estaing
nicolas sarkozy ou jacques chirac me
suis toujours dit que quelques hommes
politiques soient même si je m'en moque
arrivé à ce niveau là c'était quand même
qu'il y est intelligent mais de là à les
leur chercher le cerveau non ça je crois
que non chirac
pourquoi j'irais du président on aurait
pu parce qu'ils voient des coûts oui
donc ce serait vous laver les cheveux
tous les combien pourquoi cette voix qui
sont sales non c'est la question qu'ont
dans l'interview nues quand ingrate
ouais si vous deviez interdire un truc à
la télé ça serait la pub ou le porno
pour la pub
élections
des scores de l'émission
zéro vous vous êtes beaucoup moqué au
début de votre carrière avec jean poiret
des interviews à la télévision ce même
été le début de votre carrière
donc vous allez le payer ce soir on va
faire une interview nul
on le bouge pas pendant le signale
michel serrault qu'est ce que tu veux
est-ce que vous préfériez hitler ou
staline
je les ai pas et mesnil usa divison
parce que du jeu préféré alex et zavatta
michel serrault vous devez partir de 3
ans dans un vaisseau spatial
oui avec quelqu'un oui vous préféré
partir avec fabrice luchini edouard baer
ou josé garcia à cheikh jaber mais pas
vu parce que les autres je les connais
je connais bien je voudrais beaucoup
maigri lui j'ai pas je reconnais aussi
je vous intéresse edouard haima
l'intérêt des matières et s'il faut que
je le personnage oui il faut il faut
qu'ils ce modèle est un peu qu'il veut
mais il ya je pense que je peux lui dire
encore des choses les autres sont ils
savent ce qu'ils ont à faire
peut-être trop mais lui berne monter
encore travailler vous connaissez d'ange
blond couvrir les minions agnant cet
ange blanc qu'elle amène des des
consommations non ça mon avis et des
paquets cadeaux pour l'unicef à ben ah
bon
est-ce que vous préféreriez michel
serrault faire l'amour avec une fille
très laide très laide ou un mec très
beau je me barre we had me barre
[Applaudissements]
chaboud
attention le mot le plus qu en amour
est-ce que c'est merci encore
ou oui oui non c'est ça va aller se
terrer de sachets coup mais bon ça va
ouais je t'aime ça va hein c'était
terrible c'est con j'ai le mettre dans
mon questionnaire sahraouis s'il vous
plaît je toucherai la bombe atomique
arrive dans 5 minutes vous voit enfin
vous faites quoi quoi dans les cinq
minutes qui vous reste à vivre
je regarde ma montre jeudi j'ai plus de
4,3 avec qui passeriez-vous le plus
volontiers la nuit anne sinclair lors
sinclair ou brett sinclair après la
première
anne sinclair bah oui je la connais là
ça lui fera plaisir
michel sait bien les enfants et chante
we will sont bien quand je suis son doux
il malade il s'en suit
quel est l'animal qui embrasse le mieux
c'est mon briard la ville voulait
simplement je te j'adore ce chien il
doit il ya trois ans il est beau comme
tous les fidèles mais il ya une chose
qui m'a femmes se rendent pas compte
parce que bon ma femme dont je n'aime
pas beaucoup elle tombe pas trop élevé
mais elles sont pas très bien compris ce
qu'eux mais ça c'est autre chose moi
quand je vois mon chien j'ai
l'impression de voir une personne est
alors il se dresse il est aussi grand
que moi il à la moustache comme dans
l'armée je ne vous ça paraît rigolo
comme ça
je vous dirai ce que tu veux manger je
veux dire est ce que tu crois qu'il peut
devenir un humain je crois qu'il faut
faut arrêter les pétards
il faut arrêter de fumer la moquette
michel à cette section interrégionaux
mail un aspect faire attention
michel on est tous les deux oui on est
bloqué dans un chalet au tyrol
oui il a beaucoup neigé on ne peut pas
bouger du chalet oui on a rien à manger
ah je meurs de faim vous êtes obligé de
me manger vous commencez par quelles
parties de mon corps comme on sait pas
ce que ça me paraît elles sont assez
belle et importante
sa puissante frappe pas en mal mal mal
je vais te manger les oreilles
ils n'ont semblent-ils a toutefois
menacé tout comme un annuaire c'est un
plombage à l'oreille
oui c'est vrai qu'elle est à votre avis
michel serrault le sport le plus con
c'est lui qu'on fait pas si vous étiez
en vente dans un sex shop vous seriez
quoi je pense qu'ils vont de là dedans
[Musique]
j'ai la mémoire qui flanche bien et très
bien
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai ce n'est pas
tout petit rempart et toi tu irais je
fais thierry ardisson voilà michel
serrault nous allons glisser
sur l'auto
comme assommés
pierre vieu nul en hébreu
cependant le signal alors allons-y
pierre palmade ça tombe sur vous vous
devez partir dans un vaisseau spatial
pendant trois ans est-ce que vous
préféré partir avec elizabeth teissier
madame de fontenay ou nadine de
rothschild amp cie est déjà dans les
étoiles donc je la trouvais que je
l'aimais
qui d'autre madame de fontenay et ses
miss france où nadine de rothschild je
pense elle que je connais pas nadine
nadine alors jean michel jarre si vous
aviez le choix vous préféreriez faire
l'amour avec une fille très laide ou
avec un mec très beau au qe2 peut-être
ou et peut-être oui ptête ouais enfin il
faut voir c'est difficile ça dépend de
ses dépens de la laideur et de la beauté
c'est ce qu'on a fait est très subjectif
la laideur la sublime rachel est
vraiment moche est quand même très
dirigé ta réponse a est ce que tu as
quand même très envie qu'ils disent
jamais
combien va nous est du sport cette
question merci
alors c'est à vous maintenant le mot le
plus con en amour c'est merci encore
ou oui oui laurie jusqu'au mariage
j'irai à dire le mot le plus con amour
merci mais le plus con je vais te dire
c'est quelqu'un mais je dis c'est chez
quelqu'un qui m'a reconnu pendant les
rapports aller à qui j'étais rentré
comme si la personne était un peu on
brûle mais moi aussi et c'est pendant
les rapports la personne a ouvert les
yeux aux gens veulent me faire un petit
peu déstabilisé jean michel est ce que
vous savez vous lécher la langue des
signes à partir d'aujourd'hui non mais
c'est un bon socialiste lors il cite
vous lécher la langue abc si on peut en
perdre la nation contre eux mais je sais
je sais on fait le deuil on
il faut s'aider du palais ouais normal
vous lécher la moustache josé
laissez-les alors qu'en fait c'est pas
dur finale de plus si large avait
déclenché la langue c'est un peu con
mais c'est pas nous
social services publics bien attention
talent made nous sommes seuls qui tous
les deux vous et moi d'accord bloqué
l'hiver dans un chalet il fait très
froid il ya trois mètres de neige
on a rien à bouffer je meurs de froid
vous mourrez de faim
vous me manger vous commencez par quoi
le mandat josé mazères est de dire
qu'est ce qu'une meyer dans ce cas le
meilleur temps dans l'arctique au bo
puis sow un mot qui sonne dollar 10 ans
et vous j'ai le bas des oreilles c'est
pas mal la douce à pour commencer à
celle là c'est là les durs jean michel
vous préféreriez être réincarné en slip
de françois hollande
ah je sais que françois bayrou ou de
nicolas sarkozy ça c'est très très dur
ce qui est bien quel est le plus propre
at on alors choisir dans quel ce qu'ils
voulaient être réincarné ce que vous
savez que vous serez réincarné en slip
je me suicide allez je me suicide avant
avant d'incarner apparemment quand on se
suicide n'est pas regardée dans
l'oreille vous pierre palmade vous
préféreriez être incarnée en slip de
françois hollande de françois bayrou ou
de nicolas sarkozy alors comment comment
on peut savoir qu'elle prend preuve
nicolas sarkozy c'est ce que je connais
françois bayrou le matin à face sans
slip et au beurre pommade
[Applaudissements]
bien alors jean michel jarre ça tombe
sur vous vous préféreriez mourir comme
otis redding dans un crash d'avion
john lennon un shot à bout portant
janis joplin une audi no vers dose ou
comme john bonham le batteur de led zep
qui est mort étouffé dans son vomi
ça c'est pas une question nul sauf le
dernier cas ouais je dirais john lennon
en général moins que ce soit rapide à
bout portant
ouais ouais et vous voilà enfin je
voudrais pas donner des idées aux jambes
est assassinée jeudi à crash d'avion je
suis portrait paraît est une ode et
c'est pas terrible si vous étiez en
vente dans un sex-shop vous seriez quoi
je parle c'est tout bête vous un truc
flatteur
moguai flatteur moi je dis virilement
facteurs d'accord jean michel vous
seriez quoi nous étions avant dans un
sex-shop un mode d'emploi à temps d'y
penser ça tombe sur vous vous aimeriez
avoir un et supplémentaires un oeil
supplémentaires un doigt supplémentaire
alors ou alors quoi un sexe oui
évidemment un supplémentaire de sexe là
où vous n'auriez 2 non c'est pas mal bah
oui un oeil à neuss et ça fait un peu
mon jeu tandis qu'un chèque
supplémentaire co2 attendait jean michel
un sexe d'homme en plus ou un sexe de
femme avait une bonne question
ça serait pas mal de sexe et les deux
ouais les deux et vous moi j'ai déjà les
deux le pire est à venir
maintenant c'est l'interview nul
on ne bouge pas pendant l'été galles
bien pour l aider à olivier si vous
voyez qu'à un moment il reste du mal en
tant que vieux copain de débauche vous
pouvez les voilà alors est-ce que vous
préfériez votre père ou votre mère à ses
interviews nul je vous ai prévenus je
préférais mes grands mères
ouais le mot le plus con en amour pour
vous c'est merci alors où
oui oui alors heureuse et pour vous
alors oui pour toi c'est quoi le mot le
plus couramment
moi je parle pas
imaginez que vous croisiez un
extraterrestre le matin comme ça acheter
des cigarettes
il vous dit t'es qui toi vous répondez
quoi et toi si vous étiez en vente dans
un sex-shop vous sauriez quoi vacciner
vous soyez quoi comme objet un
préservatif mais vous dire pourquoi
parce que c'est exactement la même chose
que les metteurs en scène les
préservatifs
ça rassure quand on en main mais quand
il y en a pas qu'est ce que c'est bon
maintenant une question nul qui m'a été
envoyé par email parce que vous pouvez
m'envoyer des questions adhérents par
gym de béthune savez vous pourquoi les
abribus n'abrite pas les bus je me le
dis bravo pour la question si vous aviez
un fair play chez vous voulu apprendre
briller quelle phrase tu à fermer le gaz
tu as pensé à la capote ou coco arrête
là coco je dois apprendre et à ses
acquis attributs riez vous le plus de
circonstances atténuantes
un vieux qui se tape des jeunes où un
jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles il le
vieux qui stoppe dit rien ouais
alors vous préféreriez passé la nuit
avec anne sinclair lors sinclair ou
brett sinclair
ben je vivais l'irak 5e parce que ton
épaule et deux autres et ça lui fera
plaisir et vous perso moi je vois ça je
veux pas passer la nuit toute façon non
c'est moi j'ai toujours vu ces choses là
comme une livraison mais c'est à dire
que y'a une heure d'arrivée une heure de
départ
je vais vous les chiens une question de
michel drucker que j'ai piqué
oui je réponds oui c'est ce qu'on dit
généralement je vais bientôt le voir de
coeur je vais bientôt le voir
entraînez vous à vous la poser le
brasseur combien
a sion avec mon père au théâtre de la
porte saint homme
avec ce jeune
mais on ne bouge pas pendant le jingle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
le trop de bafé sismique est ce que
c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
interview nul vous êtes prêt ou est tiré
est ce que vous préférez votre père ou
votre mère
je préfère noël mamère ouais est-ce que
vous paierez hitler ou staline à staline
away away qui n'a tué plus de gens
vachement plus 40 millions en plus donc
je pense que le mec est plus fort et des
bulletins des cas alors vous partez
trois ans dans un vaisseau spatial
3 si l'on a déjà j'y vais pas c'est long
trois ans vous avez le choix entre trois
personnes
thomas valentin le directeur des
programmes de m6 dominique farrugia
le directeur des programmes de canal +
où etienne mougeotte j'aurais fait je
réfléchis même pas à etienne mougeotte
ah ouais on doit bien se marrer avec lui
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous pourriez faire l'amour
avec une fille très laide ou un mec très
beau mais en général je préfère tout
simplement faire l'amour avec avec ceux
ou celles qui veulent quoi d'accord sans
que soient obligés d'efforts c'est parce
que moi je n'aime pas taper et à bouger
j'ai pleuré j'ai du showbiz
il y a
bien qu est ce qui me fait peur tout
seul artiste est passé à l'action
j'espère julien lepers tulle est ce que
vous pouvez faire arriver on réincarné
en bataille ou en fontaine alors
attention un indice ne s'affiche pas sur
votre écran annie donne ni l'un ni
l'autre avant ben répond c'était
évidemment la connerie france ramène
applaudissez pas même vous rendez compte
que vous applaudissez n'importe quelle
série publique de télévision
tu connais ça alors vous allez me faire
laplaud drucker on l'a répété claude
rich r c'est comme ça je vais me faire
la peau du corps
ouais
nous n'utilisons pas la bienvenue a
changé
patrick bonnel c'est bien d'un peuple au
caire ils ont fait des programmes à plus
de rigueur alors un ami débarque chez
vous à l'improviste âgées pas d'amis ce
qui vous gêne le plus qu'ils trouvent
sur votre table de nuit
mein kampf oui l'effroyable imposture de
thierry meyssan ou un godemiché alors
franches sans hésiter thierry meyssan
parce que je dois vous dire que je les
regardais dans votre émission à thierry
et j'ai fait au [ __ ] mais donc mais
tout les qu'une immense supercherie et
ça se trouve suppléant sécurité et après
je les ai vus dans d'autres émissions de
télé se faire démonter la gueule et je
me suis aperçu donc cet homme qui avait
l'air ma foi assez gentil était
peut-être un petit peu fanfreluches donc
tu adores la science donc thierry
meyssan la réponse viendra de bordeaux
capotage si vous aviez un perroquet oui
voulu apprendriez ta ferme et le gaz
tout ce que vous dites ça parce que je
suis d'origine juive du haut c'est pas
bien alors applaudissements à la maurice
herzog
enfermé le gall ta pensée la capote une
coco arrête là coco je vais dire je vais
dire t'as pensé atteindre le gaz parce
que chez moi c'est les plaques
électriques pour elle en fut alors vous
préféreriez mourir comme otis redding
dans un crash d'avion
john lennon tué à bout portant claude
françois dans une baignoire avec un si
tu veux je sais pas quoi john bonham le
batteur de led zep étouffé dans son vomi
ou janis joplin par overdose
voilà quel programme est une star fois
prendre à mourir comme une star mais
quand même je préférais mourir comme
comme comme patrick roy a on n'en parle
pas assez d'eux patrick rondat je trouve
ça bien dommage
ouais non comme philippe de dieuleveult
dans l'incertitude la plus totale
c'est gai cette émission il est mort
qu'est-ce qu'on fait serge il est mort
allez merci c'était super j'ai adoré
michaël youn
non je vais rester
est-ce que vous préféreriez avoir un nez
supplémentaires un oeil supplémentaires
a indiqué quoi un sexe supplémentaires
pourquoi pourquoi pas ce que je vais
vous dire la vérité
ballet match ce soir le jour de la
distribution des beats way
malheureusement dans la file d'attenté
gt gt à la fin et donc j'ai eu un jeu
j'en ai eu une vraie merde quoi
c'est exact dans une émission fait
l'interview de lippi ah oui oui je
crains qu'elle ne souhaiterait nul d1
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous préfériez votre père ou
votre mère mon père j'ai pas eu le temps
de m'en lasser parce que j'ai eu un père
très distrait donc de temps en temps il
vernet qui me kim attrapé qui me met
anglais complètement tout ça je me dis
j'ai eu peur c'était mon père et puis
j'avais plus de nouvelles pendant cinq
ans donc ça le bon mon père voilà mon
père c'était ça quant à ma mère
ma mère c'est devenu un personnage de
fiction
j'en ai fait un personnage sur scène on
ne se voit plus beaucoup
je pense que
elle n'était pas dans la rue le 1er mai
dans les manifestants non non non non
minutes y'a prescription est l'étagé
préfériez staline ou hitler il faudrait
compter les morts
ouais bah savoir lequel des deux tués le
plus sali je refuse de me prononcer je
préfère quand badge of key qui a été
épatant et c'est une des plus grandes
injustices des histoires que quand bois
de chauffe n'ai pas réussi à faire ce
qu'il voulait la pérestroïka et qu'on
ait mis ce soûlard de delsinne et
maintenant cette extraordinaire serial
killer qui est in
il me fait peur lui quand j'ai vu le
camp du bien
avec bush le champion de la peine de
mort
poutine le tueur de tchétchènes et yann
ces mines l'homme de la place tiananmen
le camp du bien
mais ce spatiale vous partez trois ans
dans un vaisseau spatial russe avaient
trucs connus
non non non on revient un petit peu à la
politique française vous préféré partir
avec sarkozy juppé ou alliot marie je
comprends c'est dur c'est pas facile
comme j'ai du coeur je pars avec alliot
marie je la belle eau
alors si vous aviez le choix ou
préfériez faire l'amour avec une fille
moche très moche ou un mec très beau
votre jet depuis que je veux tu iras que
je vais chez toi tu aideras petit
frisson me faire [ __ ] une question
qui vous concerne
à qui accordez-vous le plus de
circonstances atténuantes
un vieux qui se tape des petites ou un
jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles ya des
vieilles jardiner revente
à accepteriez-vous guy bedos d'échanger
une paralysie générale tlf à l'origine
contre la faim de la famine en afrique
non je n'en si j'avais si jamais la
paralysie vrai je demanderai comme la
fille là qu'on a vu et je demanderai
l'euthanasie le droit de mourir dans la
dignité pour moi c'est quelque chose de
fantastique donc alors d'accord le futur
afrique la tétraplégie et l'euthanasie
derrière voilà bien je veux bien parce
que je suis un peu fatigué se voit pas
trop si vous aviez un perroquet voulu
apprendriez ta ferme et le gaz tu as
pensé à la capote ou coco arrête là coco
ses conséquences
or c'est le service public en tant qu
est la coucou c'est un mec qui sait qui
a préparé ces instituts privés prix là
quel est à votre avis le sport le plus
con moi je veux pas perdre des clients
un voyage en est là pour vous le curling
qui 6 à 6 là où il ya un mec qui
balaient devant la truck qu'avance tu
sais ah oui oui messi considéré comme
bien entendu tellement de mecs qui font
de curling qui vont voir vos spectacles
toute façon - non non oui je prends pas
de grands risques la halle est d'accord
je chef ça y est
sa maman il s'était remarié être
réincarné en marguerite duras soit en
miles monroe a je crois là au point où
on en est en marie malroux parce que
j'ai beaucoup de sympathie pour arthur
muller j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer
j'ai même adapté une de ses pièces et
avoir une histoire d'amour totalement
virtuel avec arthur muller et des normes
ni bar j'ai une légion érection là rien
qui avance est préféré à un président de
la république d'extrême droite élu au
suffrage universel ou pas d'élection du
tout un président de la république
d'extrême droite
la question est mal formulée ça ne va
pas ensemble
il n'y a pas de république d'extrême
droite et à l'extrême droite où il ya la
république
maintenant ça va être dur pour vous les
livre à la ligne jaune habitat qu'est ce
qui valut d'ailleurs very tough lenny
vérité avec fernand forest quoi oui
d'accord interview nul
[Applaudissements]
à lenny kravitz ya est-ce que vous
préfériez votre père ou votre mère est
super d'interviewer told you be for war
non mais moi je t'ai fissa fissa maman
est ce que vous préférez lennon
mccartney le nom c'était quelqu'un sait
ce qu'il a fait tout seul c'était
quelque chose vous préférez jagger
richards s'est hissé de m'embrouiller là
puisque ces jours là ils ont mon numéro
de téléphone dit que j'allais passer ces
deux personnes
vous avez travaillé avec mick jagger sur
son disque solo vous savez à quoi on ne
peut pas avoir un sens ou l'autre
deux numéros en même temps vous en
sortir question suivante si vous aviez
le choix est ce que vous préféreriez
faire l'amour avec une fille très laide
ou un mec très beau je pense que je
prendrai la chine est inquiète
vous devez partir trois ans dans un
vaisseau spatial lenny kravitz est ce
que vous préféreriez partir avec kylie
minogue natalia imbruglia ou vanessa
paradis
vanessa là où elle a déjà quelqu'un pour
l'instant il n'est pas possible sinon
territoire voilà très bien là toutes les
trois est-ce que vous préféreriez vous
réincarner en elvis presley bob dylan ou
eminem terlet bob dylan dylan la bombe
atomique va tomber dans cinq minutes
vous faites quoi l'amour avec ses deux
filles
ok mon mari gilles auriel 2
pour les non non ça va très bien a
simulé à tapotage tapotage vous trouvez
votre fiancée au lit avec un homme
qu'est ce que vous faites vous les
rejoignez vous frapper l'homme où vous
pleurez oui oui
allons-y rejoignant lake d'accord alors
il est cocu mais sympa question très
importante pour vous qui êtes une star
du rock est ce que vous préféreriez
mourir comme otis redding dans un crash
d'avion comme john lennon tué à bout
portant
comme john bonham
étouffé par votre vos mii ou est-ce que
vous préféreriez mourir comme janis
joplin d'une overdose afin qu'à je pense
que la mort de diana s'étaient vu deux
ou plus oui si vous étiez en vente dans
un sex-shop
que seriez-vous comme objet à biogaz ma
chérie j'ai fait la machine en garde m
le mot le mot le plus con en amour pour
vous est ce que c'est
merci merci ce type là oh là là en
risque c'est que tu vois est-ce que
c'est merci encore ou oui oui oui c'est
mais vous qu'est ce que vous pensez
une fille comme ça c'est ce que j'aime
encore
vous avez dit que cette émission était
parfois nul vous allez avoir droit
michel serrault à une interview nul
[Musique]
michel serrault vous devez partir
vous devez partir michel serrault je
dois parties devaient partir trois ans
ou alors tu me croisant dans un vaisseau
spatial avec quelqu'un vous êtes deux
dans ce vaisseau spatial vous devez
partir est ce que vous choisissez
thierry ardisson marc olivier fogiel ou
co et trois ans dans le vaisseau spatial
je crois que je t'emmène assez gentille
non mais l'ouverture ils essaient de
deux points c'est un peu les gens pour
que cette soirée où cette émission est
un peu de piment et c'est normal est
anormal mais tu sais ce que tu as à tes
un bon fond c'est vrai c'est vrai tu
n'es pas méchant mais c'est bien que tu
t'en quelquefois un peu bête mais alors
michel est ce que vous préférez être
peint ces mordus ou pic et pic et je le
suis donc ça ex que vous accepteriez
d'échanger une paralysie générale contre
la fin définitive des inondations au
bangladesh paralysie générale aux gens
c'est l'inde qui montre la fin des
inondations bangladesh en même temps
ben voui voui c'est intéressant je veux
sauver des vies 1 il faut que je
consulte un avocat tu seras paralysé
jusqu'à la fin de tes jours nous
faisions pas tous des jeunes écoutent
franchement à mentir pour l'eau
aujourd'hui un style jazzy je vais pas
te répondrais je comprends quand j'irai
un peu moins bien je te dirai à lons vie
[Applaudissements]
si vous disparaissez émission zéro
acquis confieriez-vous votre enfant à
fabrice luchini ou à pierre arditi et
jeux au couple il car ils font vraiment
beaucoup
vous avez commis un crime à qui demander
vous de cacher le corps aux gendarmes
avoir aux gendarmes et aux parents
quel est l'animal qui embrasse le mieux
michel la limace michel serrault est-ce
que vous préféreriez mourir tout de
suite là maintenant et aller au paradis
ou vivre trente ans de plus et aller en
enfer
je crois que je
la réalisation intéressante vas-y on est
tous les deux dans un chalet à la neige
en quelle horreur il fait pas toi
l'année
il fait très froid on te paraît sortir
du chalet on a pu en a mangé
oui vous êtes obligé de me manger vous
commencez par quelles parties de mon
corps fait pas que ce soit plus simple
de s'enlever un peu de fond de teint ou
bien s'il est effectivement et il est
encore plus bête non alors que vous
préférez oui un président de la
république d'extrême droite élu au
suffrage universel ou pas d'élection du
tout je pense que les c il n'y a pas de
choix parce que c'est pareil
vous pouvez lire ou laisser faire les
choses
je pense qu'ils ont le même résultat
michel serrault 800 r c'est bon ça moi
michel serrault aimeriez-vous avoir
années supplémentaires oui un oeil
supplémentaires un doigt supplémentaire
ou un sexe et supplémentaires en fut
embêté parce que je pensais que tu
verras prêt mais ça peut servir non non
ce qui m'embête c'est avec son doigt l'a
carrément à un doigt dans ne s'est pas
très jolie comme une question ça au même
il serait pas fait ça avec l'angola
il avait un col romain il c'était autre
chose non mais de la tenue et maintenant
c'est la dernière question la plus
importante michel serrault oui vous
laver les cheveux tous les combien
eh ben ça va tu es toni pourrait être
deux fois par jour non
[Applaudissements]
silence
c'est en
millions
à
non
[Musique]